i've done a lot of dumb things for
videos but this one might just be the
dumbest hi
i'm dakota and for the next week this
bathtub is going to be my home oh why
did i sign up for this
you might be asking yourself why well
it's pretty simple i work at buzzfeed
and i'm running out of ideas
i'm gonna stay in this bathtub for a
whole week with a few exceptions i can
leave to use the toilet because i am not
waffle stomping
and when my roommate needs to take a
shower i'm also not gonna have water in
the tub the whole time because
as i learned that would kill me for
everything else though i am sticking
right here what am i getting myself into
goodbye outside world
bye oh that's really hot
shouldn't have started with a full tub
so i didn't go into this completely
unprepared i did bring a few
things into this room to make myself as
comfortable as possible because i don't
want to just survive in here
i want to thrive everything that i use
in this video is going to be linked in
the description down below
in case you want to do something as dumb
as i am or just try
any of those things out to start i have
a cushion behind me
this tray here is basically going to be
my desk where i can use my keyboard and
mouse i also have this little waterproof
notepad
next to me because if i am in this
bathtub for a week i am bound to have
some incredible shower thoughts
i don't want to forget them the coolest
thing of all check this out
i got a jacuzzi i forget this
there we go and then of course i have a
rubber duck to keep me company
outside of the tub is where things get
interesting though i have a little rack
over here
to hold all of my provisions and i have
this really cute little frigidaire
refrigerator
that i am keeping some of the colder
foods in
and then the entertainment center lg was
nice enough to send me out one of their
short throw cinnabeam projectors which
is really great because it works
in a small confined space it's going to
be basically my monitor
as well as how i watch movies and play
video games and yes i know it's overkill
but i figured if i can why not i'm the
only person i know with a home theater
in my bathroom
here goes a week what do i do
next thing i think yeah can i take a
piss
yeah well we're gonna get closer than we
ever thought we would
good doing business and you
i'd say this has been a pretty
successful day one i'm just kind of
getting used to it and
hopefully i can get some sleep i'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]
i did not sleep well all of my joints
hurt
i am six foot two and this tub is like
less than five feet long that gives you
an idea
of what it feels like
will is pretty busy in meetings today so
i can't rely on him to bring me food
but i set up something really cool and
i am excited to show it to you just
watch this all right
and order placed i ordered from shake
shack
it's only three blocks away
[Music]
okay the guy just buzzed i am going to
let him in
[Music]
i've got this let's see if this works
i think it's coming
let's see if i can reach this
lunch delicious
[Music]
i've got a few meetings today and i'm
wondering if i should take them with the
water
hey well well well
i've got that i've got this jacuzzi it's
bubbling i'm going to turn the jacuzzi
off because it's quite loud
oh that just turned it louder oh no how
do i okay wait no that turned it back on
oh
no oh why is it keep turning back on
i think it turned off the last thing i
need to happen is for this to short
circuit while i'm on video with you
important update i posted on instagram
asking what i should name my duck
and i've decided to name him arnold hey
arnold what's the point of being in the
tub
unless you're gonna hang out and relax
in it so i've lit some candles for
myself
i'm just gonna relax and see if i can
get a better night's sleep tonight
really hoping i can
[Music]
i'm standing up because i just took a
shower and i'm still waiting for the tub
to dry but last night
was really rough i felt like every part
of my body
was in the wrong position also one thing
i hadn't considered
is that i shouldn't take a bath right
before i want to go to bed
because then i have to wait for the tub
to dry before i can put my pillow
and blankets in here
[Music]
i can't afford to keep ordering food so
today i'm going to bring a toaster in
the tub
i'm just kidding but i am going to make
some avocado toast avocado
bread what more do you need i forgot to
bring plates in here
this thing got very hot very quickly
let's toast
[Music]
look at that that's beautiful look at
that it's beautiful
breakfast i feel like later i'm gonna be
bathing in bits of egg
this is the reason the housing market is
in shambles and i have to live in a
bathtub
the damn millennials and their avocado
toasts
[Music]
i realize i've been so rude i've been
asking will for all this help he's been
getting me food and i haven't even
invited him in here to watch a movie or
anything
hey will yeah do you want to watch a
movie and drink a beer in here
cheers
day three complete i'm not looking
forward to trying to sleep tonight
i am very tired though so hopefully that
will help like three in the morning
i've barely slept and i did exactly what
i was afraid of
and started dribbling water all over the
pillow
i just need to clean up the water go
back to bed i can sleep
a little bit
[Music]
i woke up today and i hurt everywhere
my back is sore my legs are completely
cramped up
i don't know if i can demonstrate this
but like my legs have to be completely
bent like this
in order to fit in this tub and over the
course of the night i feel like it's
constricting the blood flow
and it's just like making me cramp up i
just want to stretch them but i have
nowhere to do that and so i wake up
constantly
i need to move around like actually walk
so while my roommate takes a shower this
morning i'm gonna go for a quick walk
i'm not giving up i just need to like
move
for 20 minutes it's so nice out
what do i go back into this tub
[Music]
i don't want to get back in there
[Music]
halfway done
so if this is going to be my home i
figure i might as well start decorating
so i've uh i've been adding some art to
the walls
um this one i call lost arnold
and um this one is what i think paradise
looks like there's no bathtubs there
and i'm currently drawing the view out
my window if i could see out my window
i will start the bidding at one million
dollars i'm doing great
i have to finish editing a video today
but after that i think i am going to
take the rest of the day off and just
relax i'm gonna go live on twitch
stream myself playing video games from
my bathtub
it's raining i'm already wet in real
life i don't need to
get wet in minecraft ow
i don't have much health damn it
oh it's wet i got some of it off my nose
that stream tonight was really fun i
actually enjoyed myself
and i kind of forgot what i was doing
for a little bit and it kind of just
made me realize that like yeah i can do
this
it's gonna be hard it has been hard but
like it's possible
and i'm almost there
good morning from day five i just took a
shower if you couldn't tell
last night i decided to sleep sitting up
which i usually try to avoid because i
can never stay asleep long that way like
i can't sleep on buses or planes or
anything
however maybe it's because the last few
nights of sleep have been truly awful or
maybe i'm just built different
but i've managed to sleep mostly through
the night also it's friday which means
i've just got a few days left of this
and then i'm
free i was sitting here trying to figure
out what to do with my day and it struck
me
that arnold needed a friend and so i've
been converting this shampoo bottle into
a friend for arnold
her name is dove they're getting married
and all the soaps are invited
just look at them so happy together
[Music]
whoops
i wonder how long i can hold my breath
underwater i'm gonna try it
oh i'm out of practice but not terrible
i invented a game since i have a tennis
ball i have a roll of tape here
and all you have to do is bounce the
tennis ball off this ah and into the
roll
i'm really bad at it okay
let's call my mom she picked up what's
up
i just wanted to call and say hi i am in
my bathroom
my home theater set up over there that's
great right over the toilet
yeah it's perfect of there yet your
mother's worried about your well-being
i'm gonna be fine don't worry are you
comfortable
um sure
i'm sure i owe him something big time
he has gone to the neighbors to use the
bathroom
[Music]
for content tucker for content
it's my last day in this tub i'm
actually about to get out
in just a few minutes i didn't expect it
to be this hard
i mean i i should have in retrospect i
should have
thought wow that's not a good idea you
shouldn't get in that tub
but i did and here i am the past seven
days i've left this tub for probably
an hour total just in times where i
needed to like
change my clothes or grab something that
i really needed
it took its toll i physically don't feel
great
like my body feels kind of achy and
honestly i think the hardest part has
been the boredom
i'm lucky i had a bunch of fun stuff to
do in here because if i hadn't i would
have
completely not been able to get through
this
there's no profound thing coming out of
this this was just a nightmare
this was not a pleasant time i do not
recommend it to anybody
don't do it i might have to move i don't
know if i want to see this bathroom
anymore
all right oh
[Music]
okay ooh my butt's wet
[Music]
i'm free
[Music]